[Music]
people are afraid of mathematics it's
it's a source of fear and anxiety many
people think of mathematics is dull
formulas in a textbook and it could not
be further from the truth
I'm any word and I teach high school
mathematics in Sydney Australia my
grandparents were born in China they
fled there during the world wars and
came to Malaysia where my parents were
born and they themselves left that
country to come here Australia because
they valued education I was a student
who struggled with mathematics and I
would be the person who put up my hand
and said wait can you explain it again
and it took me hours and hours beating
my head against the textbook trying to
understand and so when I got to
university inside to train to become a
teacher
I thought about mathematics in a very
different way I discovered what
mathematics was I discovered that its
its patterns that are woven into the
universe
students need someone who believes in
them every student which is as a
champion someone who is going to
absolutely place the utmost faith in
them and never give up on them
one of my favorite ways to get kids
engaged with mathematics is to simply
show them a card trick we don't know
very much about these cards but
mathematically I can actually see
through and know there's a pattern
underneath here that you cannot see yet
he's a pretty famous teacher in
Australia but he's about personal
relationships there's lots of talking
there's lots of passion and he's always
looking for the way to get every single
student in the class to understand the
concept how many cards did you get that
matched on both sides
I've heard people who got a 10-8 four
and four I've heard a seven and seven a
six and six ah the context blew my mind
like oh that was so cool when he just
reached that final step and then you can
just click let's go outside bring your
bottle your paper and your pen let's go
so you say your number as I come around
so what we're doing right now is we're
trying to use probability and statistics
to solve a problem and we're using
bottle flipping because kids locked up
the bottles so we're having a lot of fun
right now on your marks get set go move
and start flipping
I ain't got one I find the bottle
flipping was pretty amazing and like
something that someone made up out of
bottles makes into a math lesson it
shows students mathematics is there in
situations where you would often least
expect it every lesson that I produce is
required I know they thought they met
that Matt I started doing this several
years ago to help a sick student now
five years later there's more than a
hundred thousand people who are
subscribed to watch the videos every
time they come out and when you look at
all of the content that I've produced
they've been watched over eight million
times right now I am taking some of the
videos that I shot in my lessons and
I've edited them together I've uploaded
them what I love is that this enables
students to learn on their own terms
the videos are being watched 24 hours a
day non-stop 365 days a year
New Zealand 50,000 every African nation
Greenland 70 views that's great that
place is mostly ice I'm amazed seeing
that global reach is just it's
astonishing and it's a great privilege
for me to be able to share the knowledge
that I have with people around the world
congratulations is really good to see
you today is a celebration of everything
that our graduating students have
achieved some of them it's their best
mark that they received throughout all
of the courses that they studied I
couldn't be more delighted in what
they've achieved I used to suck at it I
hated maths and then I had mr. Wu in
year 11 I would not be where I am today
if I didn't have him as a teacher my
dream for the students who might teach
and people around the world who are
getting to watch my videos is that they
learn to understand that mathematics is
a beautiful thing
[Music]
you